Rich Eisen here having a conversation
about the unique nature to say the least
about the 2020 NFL Draft that's gonna
start going down next Thursday night and
joining me right now to talk about this
is the Commissioner of the National
Football League Roger Goodell
how are you and your family commissioner
everybody go doing great rich we're
blessed and just worrying about
everybody in our country and trying to
do the best we can to support them well
in terms of that let's talk about the
draft and what the NFL has planned for
it and in terms of obviously giving
everybody a little bit of a break a
respite maybe a place to find a sense of
normalcy why hold the draft let's start
with that there's been a lot of question
about why the NFL is continuing to move
forward with the draft I give you the
floor on that subject commissioner well
for righties as one as as you know it's
it's important to have normalcy it's
important to continue on schedule as
best as you can we've obviously modified
our schedule several times our offseason
training is different the draft itself
will be different because it's no longer
alive event we're doing it within
regulations from state to state local
regulations and federal law regulations
and so we're doing this in a way and I
think demonstrates that you can continue
to do what we need to do in this country
and do it safely from home and so that's
why you know all of our personnel will
be safe we'll be within those
regulations so we can do this in a safe
mash in fashion and you know how
important this is so in our clubs want
to get their rosters finalized they want
to be moving forward and when we get
done with this they'll go right into a
virtual offseason that we've negotiated
with our players associations so we want
to keep on schedules as best we can and
doing it safely for all our participants
including the draft eligible players who
will be joining in virtually and all of
that it's going to be something I think
hopefully inspire our country but also
as you point out it's giving us a
platform to thank the people who are on
the front line the people that have been
risking their health and their families
and and we want to make sure that we're
recognizing them the health care workers
and the first responders and our
military and make sure we we have a
great opportunity here to provide relief
funds for so many people that are in
need today yeah and there's six
charities uh that that are specifically
going to be involved with the draft a
thon as we're calling it our draft a
thon live and getting to that in just
just a moment but in terms of again
having the draft and any initial
pushback that there may have been on
that from either member clubs or others
that are concerned about how the draft
is going to be done have you to your
knowledge or comfort heard from any of
the clubs on this front going into the
final week of preparations from the
draft about still going ahead with this
Commissioner yeah I think all our clubs
are you know focused on executing on the
draft we've worked with the technology I
think people are comfortable with the
technology which is important we have a
lot of great partners are helping lists
of that but you know we're doing I think
we're doing all we need to do to make
sure we do this with a great deal of
sensitivity but also make sure that
operationally it comes off well for the
clubs and our ownership was fully behind
us
every owner suggested that we continue
to stay on schedule and do the drafts
and frankly there were really many
alternatives rich if we were delaying
this when we were delaying it till what
are the solutions we needed to move
forward because and we needed to do it
differently and I think that's the key
thing we are doing this draft
differently and that that relates to
some anxiety and I understand that but I
think our clubs are adapting really well
well in terms of doing it differently
certainly the broadcast yeah I guess
proof of that visual proof of that with
ESPN and NFL Network combining together
for a single broadcast on multiple
platforms and then of course there is
what we're gonna get into a little bit
more heavily right now and that we're
announcing right now
draft Athan live which is going to be a
digital and social tour de force of
covering this draft that I am thrilled
to be hosting and I'm wondering why you
wanted something like that to go down
commissioner because we know what's
going on in our country were part of
those communities were we want to give
back in you know we're coming out even
before we announce the draft Athan with
nearly 50 million dollars as initial
funds that are there and we hope to
obviously be able to do much better than
that over the next few weeks and be able
to do something that is going to provide
really needed resources for people on
the front line and that have been
impacted by this and that's a that's
what we do rich as you know we have a
great platform this is a great platform
we think we can bring a lot of attention
and a lot of thanks and gratitude to the
people who are on the front lines but
also much-needed resources and in terms
of the resources of the NFL virtually
every social platform that the NFL has
is going to get this draft Athan I don't
you should you want me to throw this out
there or do you want to tell us what
this is all about I mean I just I just
want to go through what what this draft
Athan life really is if people
understand what's coming well I think
what it's going to do is really give
people a chance to participate and to to
give back in in their own way and
forever whatever amount that they can to
be able to contribute to relief efforts
from some great organizations six
national organizations that will be
getting the funds a hundred percent of
those funds and that's that's real
important for us and to support the work
that they're doing and this is an
opportunity for everyone to to be able
to enjoy an NFL event but also be able
to make sure that it's
going to a really great cause and
everyone to participate in a unique way
yeah and just to walk through that right
now nfl.com slash relief is where people
can go to right now take a look at all
the details involving draft athon and
certainly involving six national
nonprofits in their respective relief
efforts to fight kovat 19 the American
Red Cross being one the CDC foundations
all of us combat combat coronavirus
campaign feeding America's kovat 19
response fund Meals on Wheels kovat 19
response fund as we know that this virus
is hit the population that is the most
vulnerable absolutely elderly is hit it
very hard Salvation Army and United Way
which has been associated with the NFL
for decades at the United Way's Cova 19
community response and recovery fund and
throughout this entire draft I thought I
know just speaking for for me it's going
to be an honor to be hosting this not
only because you know it's what we do
with the NFL media group for an
important event like this and we do want
to cover the draft but we also want to
raise as much money as possible and do
that all in a way that is entertaining
and informative and I personally can't
wait for it to be very honest with you
well we can't either rich and we we have
a great host and a great co-host with
Deion and I know you're gonna have a lot
of special hosts and I think it's gonna
be really entertaining as well as an
opportunity for people to give back and
and to support the things that are going
on in each of our communities and on a
national basis these organizations are
best-in-class
they're doing incredible work and and we
all need to support them and my family
and I are proud to be in and I know
others are going to be participating in
this in a way that it's gonna make us
all really feel good about the end of
this draft that not only did our teams
all get better did we all restore a
little hope in our teams but also
looking forward and looking towards the
future and and making sure that we all
realize that we still have a bright
future
and this is a chance for all of us to to
help ensure that well in the few minutes
that we have left I do want to hit on
the future itself I know that you've
been involved in some conversations with
the president vice president and other
commissioners of other sports leagues
what is the stance of the NFL right now
as we're sitting here about a playing
season and a schedule that might be
coming in May commissioner well we are
planning on putting our schedule out our
game schedule by May 9th
we are planning as you can tell by the
draft and by the start of the league
year and by the trying to adjust to the
environment we're operating in that
we're planning and working towards
staying on schedule we will be
announcing our schedule by then and we
intend to do everything possible to stay
focused on that and make sure that we
can be prepared to execute on that
because that's where we think we'll be
ok and obviously the virus will set
maybe a timeline that is not known right
now obviously it is the it is the NFL
considering more truncated season or
there other I mean you've given
directives to those who are putting the
schedule together on that car listen
rich you know one of the things we
always do is we consider public safety
and everything we do it's important for
our fans or participants our partners
all be safe so we're we're obviously
going to have that in our forefront as
we're making our plans and none of us
know what the the conditions will be you
know a week from now much less three
months from now or six months from now
so we'll be prepared for all
alternatives that's what we do and we'll
make sure that we're ready to just we're
working with all the authorities you
mentioned the president's got all of the
sports together I think people want to
see sports back we want to do it safely
and we want to do it safely for
everybody and so we're all working
together to make sure we find ways to do
that supporting one another but making
sure that we do our part to get the
economy going and get people back in a
place where we have some sense of normal
and is there is there some date by which
you may have
out there discussing amongst the the
league by which you need to make a
decision no rich that's why we're going
to be prepared right we're prepared and
we're moving on the basis of making sure
we're ready for the season and you know
we'll have to adjust if something you
know in some way interferes with that
and and it's in the best interest of
Public Safety okay
and in terms of the draft a lot has been
made about from where you will be
announcing are you is there is there a
Commissioner mancave that we're gonna be
led into that were there actually is a
Commissioner mancave and you will you
will get a front-row seat it's it's
where I do watch games on Sundays in the
fall when I'm home and not traveling or
in the office but it's you know again
it's part of the stay at home effort
stay at home stay strong and we want to
make sure that we're doing this the
right way no one is going to be at the
facilities as you know we've closed all
NFL facilities across elite we obviously
aren't doing this the same way we did it
with the Las Vegas fans but we'll be
back hopefully in Las Vegas shortly but
we're gonna do this in a way I think
that's going to be entertaining and fun
and the people in sight how teams are
building their rosters okay and will
your family be there for the first pick
add some sort of energy to the draft
call or anything like know we you know
as you know we're restricted in the
number of people to be in the room so
it's functional people only as they say
so and don't tell my family I said they
weren't functional so so if you need if
you you know obviously it's gonna be a
long night if you need any sort of
coffee or any caffeine at the end of the
night I have something for you I'm gonna
send there Rich Eisen show mob for you
you got it here's the problem it'll be
hot chocolate because I'm not a coffee
drinker but that's okay oh yeah I think
that's that's that might be the biggest
news of all right here by the way
by the way I won't need energy on on
draft night this is one of my favorite
nights there's going to be a lot of
interaction of course virtual with the
draft eligible players I'm actually
having a conference call or several
conference calls with all of the draft
eligible players that would have been in
attendance in Las Vegas and we'll have a
lot of interaction with them and I think
all of us are looking forward to that it
would be different but it'll be fun I
bet it will be for sure well this is
where this is where I'll be right here
isn't it the Rich Eisen man-cake it's
not I don't have a man cave but it is
just might my setup I've got books that
I haven't read in a very long time
behind me if you've noticed everybody's
got books behind them in their home
office setting to make it look like
they're well-read but that is that is me
at the greatest institution of higher
learning at the University of Michigan
going out on the field I got that going
on here I knew you were gonna get that
plug in that makes two plugs now that
makes you know there is an iron-rich and
Eisen I'm thrilled to be I'll be here
for the draft earth on Thursday night
Friday night on all the social media
partners all the digital platforms the
teams will be involved nfl.com every
everybody pulling together and we'll try
and raise as much money as possible
you're gonna do a great job and I look
forward to being with you when I can in
between picks but I I think you're gonna
be spectacular and we're looking forward
to it and know that we're gonna do some
great work that night so thank you I'll
be sure to give you the password to the
room so you can get rich that's your
luck yeah that's the Commissioner of the
National Football League right here
you